[Music]
on this friday night the election
campaign heads into the home stretch
you've got no interest in doing
something you promised no cost with a
fiery debate night behind them the
leaders turned their attention to key
battlegrounds and could a controversial
question in the english debate be a
boost for the block
boosting immunity the recommendation for
a third shot and who should get it plus
serving stardom the canadian teen tennis
phenom overpowering opponents all the
way to the u.s open final and a return
to gander planes are on top of each
other coming down the newfoundland town
where residents opened their doors and
their hearts on a devastating day 20
years ago
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the debates are over and the final
push is now underway in the federal
election campaign today advance polls
opened across the country and with
election day just 10 days away the two
front runners came out swinging today
hoping to sway voters before they cast
their ballots
there's lots of really big things that
we are in the process of doing if we
change government all those things
aaron o'toole has indicated that he will
roll them back all we've seen for mr
trudeau
is more scaremongering
more spending higher taxes more broken
promises
and no solutions
aaron o'toole focused his campaign today
in the vote rich greater toronto area
it's considered crucial for any party
hoping to form government our david
aiken is traveling with the conservative
campaign david
well farah aaron o'toole's riding is
right on the tip of the greater toronto
area durham and because of that he feels
he has some insight into how to unlock
votes inside the gta
we need to rebuild trust
with some canadians including
some suburban folks in ontario and we've
worked very hard to do that
meanwhile o'toole will argue the liberal
leader no longer deserves the trust of
gta voters justin trudeau
came to power promising a new way of
doing things
you remember he promised sunny ways he
said he rejected the politics of
division and was offering hope
and hard work
where did that justin trudeau go
there are 57 ridings in the gta that's
more than in any province except quebec
and the liberals hold 49 of them on
friday both o'toole and trudeau will end
their day in the riding of whitby that
is right on the gta's eastern fringe at
the border of tory blue ontario and the
liberals gta fortress the writing of
whitby has been liberal since justin
trudeau became prime minister in 2015
but it was conservative when stephen
harper was prime minister and so this
writing is the classic example of the
kind of battleground that aaron o'toole
has to win
if he wants to be prime minister
i'm abigail beeman covering the liberals
in this final stretch of the campaign
justin trudeau is trying to stick to his
message that this election is about
choice when aaron o'toole is proposing
to bring us back
to harper's approach on climate change
i am going to be ferocious in standing
up for canadians and relentless in
pushing forward for the better world the
party feels o'toole has given them easy
openings to attack on gun control
climate and ripping up the popular
liberal 10 a day child care plans the
race has been so tight and thursday's
debate didn't seem to change things with
their government on the line liberals
are targeting the catch-all of
progressive voters meaning the ndp are
in their sights as well concerned about
vote splitting i think they'll be
sending the message that a vote for mr
singh may very well just mean that the
conservatives come through and they
scrap
all the progress that we've made so far
in another point of contrast between
trudeau and o'toole friday trudeau said
the flags lowered three months ago after
the discovery of unmarked graves of
residential school children should only
come up when indigenous people are ready
to raise them o'toole says canadians
should be proud to raise them and he
would do that at the end of september
the new national day for truth and
reconciliation
abigail beeman global news hamilton
ontario an ontario man is facing charges
for allegedly threatening justin trudeau
at a campaign stop police say a
32-year-old man from kitchener is facing
two counts of uttering threats after a
protest last month in cambridge the
man's name was not released a separate
police investigation is underway in
london after gravel was thrown at
trudeau during another campaign stop
with nearly one quarter of total seats
in the country quebec is a key
battleground in the federal election
many believe the path to a majority
government goes through that province
but few expected last night's english
debate would cause such a stir in quebec
it has premier francois lego fired up
and demanding an apology michael couture
explains what happened and the fallout
that was an attack for sure
against quebec
with fire in his eyes an emotion in
every word premier francois lago
defended his province and demanded an
apology from the consortium of
broadcasters it stems from a question at
the english debate on quebec's
secularism laws which prevent public
servants teachers and police officers
from wearing religious symbols for those
outside the province please help them
understand why your party also supports
these discriminatory laws
the question seems to imply the answer
you want
those laws are not about discrimination
they are about the values of quebec
lagos says moderator shachikurl unfairly
characterized bill 21 as discriminatory
adding the law has wide support across
the province so to canadians who think
otherwise that bill 21 doesn't apply in
the rest of canada
so please
please
please
it's not of your business lego also
noted other federal leaders on the
debate stage failed to stand up for
quebec thursday night even though many
spoke up friday morning it is wrong
to suggest that quebecers are racist
as a quebecer i found that question
really offensive quebecers are not
racist and it's unfair to to make that
sweeping categorization for the leader
of the block quebecois it was too little
too late
when it was time to defend quebec values
in english thursday night says blanchet
we heard crickets
in a statement the debate broadcast
group said the specific question was
addressing quebec bills and quote did
not state that quebecers are racist end
quote so it would seem legal
is not getting the apology he wanted
farah
michael couture in ottawa thank you mike
and as global national goes on the road
ahead of the election donna friesen will
be broadcasting from quebec city on
tuesday
the five party leaders clashed over many
issues in the debate including the
pandemic but they all came together with
the united message for canadians to get
vaccinated
we're all in this together
we've come so far in the fight against
covet it's time to finish this pandemic
for good so get vaccinated vaccines are
safe and effective for use vaccines are
the best way for you to protect yourself
your family and your community
we're all in agreement this is not a
partisan issue so please get vaccinated
vaccines save lives or how we're going
to beat kovid and it's time for everyone
to do it get the shot
the national advisory committee on
immunizations is now recommending
canadians who are immunocompromised
receive a third dose of vaccine nasi
says that this applies to people 12 and
older canada's chief public health
officer says those who are moderately to
severely immunocompromised have a weaker
response to vaccines
not everyone
even mount an increased response to the
third dose but some do and so this
represents a added
layer of
increased
immunity and
in adding that additional dose of
mrna vaccine
saskatchewan is reinstating a public
health order as the province grapples
with the second highest rate of active
cases in our country those who test
positive will now have to self-isolate
for 10 days unvaccinated people will
also need to isolate if they come into
contact with positive cases the
government is expanding testing and
contact tracing
non-critical surgeries are being reduced
and booster shots are being administered
for long-term care residents and those
who are immunocompromised
the province's proof of vaccination
system will be launched the week of
september 20th
there is growing anger and frustration
tonight from doctors in alberta they're
worried the exponential spread of the
highly transmissible delta variant could
soon cause the health system there to
collapse
they're dealing with a surge of
unvaccinated patients in hospital in
edmonton a pregnant woman died from a
covid19 related infection after being
admitted to the icu
the last time hospitals were under this
much pressure the government imposed
sweeping restrictions
but not this time at least not yet
heather yorks west reports
alberta's doctors are angry it's very
hard for me to even put into words what
i'm feeling right now we saw a complete
abandonment of health and well-being for
albertans from the government dr nija
bakshi is part of a group of doctors
that have been holding regular covid19
briefing since late august the
physicians had hoped that a late
thursday announcement from alberta
health would help bend the curve of what
has become a punishing fourth wave
what the province announced was money
for home care and a plan to move up to
200 acute care patients out of hospital
and into long-term care next week i just
want to stress right now that right now
we're just we're very concerned about
our icu capacity that is our number one
challenge and our number one issue and
for that challenge home care funding is
unlikely to help despite adding more
beds alberta's intensive care units are
filling fast at one point last week
there were just nine beds available
across the province the last time the
situation was this bad was back in may
but hospital numbers peaked after the
province implemented sweeping
restrictions closing indoor and outdoor
dining fitness facilities and moving
k-12 classes online nobody wants to see
that again nobody wants to see
restrictions but the fact is what we've
done so far has not had any influence on
viral spread it continues to grow and
unless something changes we can expect
it to continue to grow emergency
medicine physician dr joe vipan says
that is a terrifying thought that means
physicians are going to have to make
choices as to who gets that life-saving
treatment of intensive care and that
means people will die who otherwise
would not have died last friday the
province introduced a mask mandate for
all indoor public spaces and a 10
o'clock curfew on liquor sales the
health minister says the province will
wait to see if those measures have an
impact before it does anything more
heather urex west global news calgary
canada's rising star on the tennis court
layla fernandez coming up the 19 year
old beats some of the best to make it
into the u.s open final to face another
teen titan
canadian leila fernandez is preparing
for the biggest match of her young
career she was ranked 73rd when she
entered the u.s open but the 19 year old
has stunned the tennis world beating out
grand slam favorites to secure her spot
in tomorrow's final and as eric sorensen
explains she's not the only teen with a
canadian connection to make history at
the tournament
[Applause]
the canadian sensation looks every bit
the astonished teenager she is and it
has swelled the hearts of new yorkers
how are you able to win that match and
be in the u.s open finals
i have no idea
i've never seen anything like this
tennis legend chris evert almost giddy
assessing montreal's leila fernandez
she's too good to be true
and how about too good to be true times
two emma ragicanu age 18 two months
younger than fernandez born in toronto
but raised in the uk has like fernandez
comes seemingly out of nowhere to this
moment i'm in the final and i can't
actually believe it thanks for everyone
against all odds both have made the
final neither with the experience or the
power of the top ranked players but are
skilled and fearless
regicanu resists comparisons to compare
yourself and your results against anyone
is is probably like the thief of
happiness fernandez family keeps her
grounded and she believes hard work has
prepared these young athletes for the
biggest stage we want to make a
difference we want to make an impact in
the in tennis and
this tournament just proves how well
we're adapting to everything it's so
remarkable and so inspiring but i think
what people have to understand is the
years and years of work and sacrifice
it's all an inspiration to fernandez
friend and playing partner it really is
encouraging you know like for us young
people to see uh
like because in the in the finals
tomorrow's gonna be like two
two teenagers playing no one foresaw
such a fairy tale final though the two
teens seem to believe all of this really
could come true it just shows that if
you believe in yourself then anything is
possible nothing's impossible there's
there's no limit to to to what i can do
only one will be champion but this u.s
open final will celebrate both young
women when sports and youth can make
impossible possible and if they're lucky
it's only the beginning
eric sorensen global news
toronto still ahead what it was like to
launch this newscast the week before the
9 11 attacks
that picture please in the control room
it's difficult to know let's take it
full frame if we can please but it looks
as if that second tower has either had
sections of it fall off or has just
collapsed
[Music]
that's a clip from a documentary airing
tonight disruption 20 years of global
national this news broadcast went to air
on september 3rd 2001 just eight days
before the deadliest terror attack on
american soil kevin newman launched
global national and was in the anchor
chair as you just saw on september 11th
and he joins me now from toronto kevin
what strikes me is you are so calm in
this clip you had just moved here from
new york to take on the global national
anchor role you knew people who were in
those buildings i'm so curious how did
you put that aside and what was that
moment like for you
well i mean you have to put it aside
because you know that canadians are
watching and they're generally quite
fearful
and so you you press it down and and
you're careful not to add to the the
panic and the fear that was in the
country on that day
you know that really was the event that
changed a whole lot
not only about how america saw itself
but how we would access america the
border became much more restrictive
especially for canadians of color
it was the beginning of the surveillance
society and it led to two wars one in
afghanistan that just seemed to end a
couple of weeks ago and one in iraq that
is still going on so it really was a
seminal event and i think it was the
beginning of two decades of disruption
that really i don't think has ended
well the documentary also explores how
news has changed tell us about that
well i think you know
this
halfway through the life uh span of
global national in 2011 uh the iphone
came out and
all the reporters were suddenly able to
go live just from their phone and that
was really important around the arab
spring
jazz joe hall one of the reporters at
the time and his cameraman
barry acton were there and their big
cameras were confiscated and so they
looked at their phones and they thought
well maybe we can report through cell
phones and that was a new idea then and
as we've seen as time has gone on the
civilian witnesses have started to drive
much more of the news agenda and we
really are living in an era now
where there are witnesses everywhere and
things happen that could be captured and
shared and i think that's had a big
impact on the news flow you know you
really connect those dots over these 20
years in terms of news events but but do
you think the age of disruption is only
20 years long or are we still in it
oh we're still in it uh i mean the the
last bit which is life disruption the
kovid
pandemic is another major story and it's
not over yet obviously as donna friesen
says in the documentary we're probably
only going to realize what profound
change that has had in two or three
years so no i think the era of
disruption we're still very much in it
kevin newman i really look forward to
seeing this documentary again and i know
our viewers will really enjoy it as well
thank you so much
thank you phil
and you can watch disruption 20 years of
global national tonight right here on
global or online at globalnews.ca
global national
i'm ross lord in gander the newfoundland
town that restored faith in humanity
following the 9 11 terrorist attacks
looking back 20 years later people here
still feel pride and they still feel
sore
that story coming up on global national
[Music]
in the moments after the september 11th
attacks planes were grounded and
thousands of airline passengers
unexpectedly found themselves in the
small town of gander in newfoundland and
labrador
residents opened their homes and their
hearts and their kindness became the
impetus for a broadway musical called
come from away
20 years later our ross lord returned
don't let the stubborn fog fool you
gander prides itself on being an airport
not an outport but there was no way to
know what was coming on september 11th
planes started to drop down to the sky
actually looking over runway 22 here
planes are on top of each other coming
down welcome to unexpected uh
visit to canada we are in gang gander in
all 38 planes landed here almost 7 000
bewildered passengers in a quiet town
that was home to just ten thousand
residents to begin with
school bus drivers who've been on strike
drove the so-called plane people to
school gymnasiums converted into
makeshift hotels gandra's hockey arena
became a warehouse for stacks of food
and drinks
and the laid-back charm of the town and
surrounding communities soon put their
distraught guests at ease one guy said
to me said
where can you go in the world
sit on the steps
of the other church
right across
from the police stations and drink a
bottle of wine it's not just that gander
accepted the so-called plain people it's
how people here embrace them and how
deeply they considered their needs the
spare room was [ __ ] and spam sheets were
as i said before many times dried on the
line because you sleep a lot better when
the sheets are drying on the line
the story is known now around the world
thanks to come from away first a hit on
broadway then beyond now there's even
talk of a hollywood movie version
in gander permanent reminders include
this chunk of steel from the world trade
center and more fragile mementos post-it
notes at the airport's emergency center
listing flight numbers the notes are
still on the wall 20 years later there
are no plans to remove them
bonds forged in hardship are often
strongest
for people here it doesn't take much for
the pride and the sorrow to return as we
speak of course there's a situation in
afghanistan and certainly something that
that you know turns the world's
attention to it again
and stirs up a lot of those emotions
again pandemic restrictions have
prevented some plain people from
returning this year to show their
gratitude but fond memories are immune
like the streams of gander drivers
pulling over to offer their visitors a
ride as they were out for a walk gander
invented the first ride sharing it was
you know the first uber was happening in
2001. problem is they just didn't charge
for it
so
they never will charge for it
20 years later their kindness is still
free
ross lord global news gander
newfoundland and labrador
such a quintessential canadian thing to
do in such a deep moment of need
that is global national for this friday
i'm far announcer thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is also in
newfoundland the gorgeous gross morning
national park robin gill will be with
you on the anchor desk tomorrow until
monday take care of yourselves and each
other
[Music]